you mentioned the sir model
i think there are certain ideas there of
growth of exponential growth what
maybe have you learned about
pandemics from from making that video
because it was kind of exploratory you
were kind of building up an intuition
and it's again people should watch the
video it's kind of an abstract view it's
not
really modeling in detail the whole
field of epidemiology
those those people they go
really far in terms of modeling like how
people move about i don't know if you've
seen it but like there
really their mobility patterns like how
like the
truck like how many people you encounter
in certain situations when you go to a
school when you go to a mall
they like model every aspect of that for
a particular city like they have
maps of actual city streets they model
it really well
and natural patterns of the people have
it's crazy so you don't do any of that
you're just doing an abstract model to
explore different ideas
of simple pedigree well because i don't
want to pretend like an epidemic i'm an
epidemiologist like we have a ton of
armchair epidemiologists
and the spirit of that was more like
uh can we through a little bit of play
uh draw like reasonable-ish conclusions
um and also just like get ourselves in a
position where we can
judge the validity of a model like i
think people should look at that and
they should criticize it they should
point to all the ways that it's wrong
because it's definitely naive
right in the way that it's set up um but
to say like what
what lessons from that hold like
thinking about the are not value and
what that represents and
what it can imply not so are not is
if you are infectious and you're in a
population which is um completely
susceptible
uh what's the average number of people
that you're gonna infect during
your infectiousness so certainly during
the beginning of
an epidemic this basically gives you
kind of the
exponential growth rate like if every
person infects two others you've got
that one two four eight
exponential growth pattern as it goes on
and
let's say it's something endemic where
you've got
like a ton of people who have had it and
are recovered
then uh you would the r naught value
doesn't tell you that as directly
because a lot of the people you interact
with aren't susceptible
but in the early phases it does and this
is like the fundamental constant that it
seems like epidemiologists look at and
you know the whole goal is to get that
down if you can get it below one then
it's no longer epidemic
if it's equal to one then it's endemic
and it's above one than your epidemic
so like just teaching what that value is
and giving some intuitions on
how do certain changes in behavior
change that value and then what does
that imply for exponential growth
i think those are um general enough
lessons and they're
like resilient to all of the chaoses of
the world
um that it's still like valid to take
from the video i mean one of the
interesting aspects of that is just
exponential growth
and we think about growth is that one of
the first times you've
done a video on on uh no
of course not the the whole
uh oilers identity okay so sure
i've done a lot of videos about
exponential growth in the circular
direction
uh only minimal in the normal direction
i mean
another way to ask like do you think
we're able to reason
intuitively about exponential growth
it's it's funny i think it's um i think
it's extremely intuitive to humans
and then we train it out of ourselves
such that it's then really not intuitive
and then i think it can become intuitive
again when you study a technical field
uh so what i mean by that is um have you
ever heard of these studies where in a
uh like anthropological setting where
you're studying a
group that has been disassociated from a
lot of like modern society
and you ask what number is between one
and nine
and maybe you would ask you you've got
like one rock and you've got nine rocks
you're like what pile is halfway in
between these
and our instinct is usually to say five
that's the number that sits right
between one and nine
um but sometimes when uh numeracy and uh
the kind of just basic arithmetic that
we have isn't in a society
the natural instinct is three because
it's
uh in between in an exponential sense
and a geometric sense that
uh one is three times bigger and then
the next one is three times bigger than
that
so it's like what's you know if you have
one friend versus a hundred friends
what's in between that yeah ten friends
seems like the social status in between
those two states so that's like deeply
intuitive to us to think logarithmically
like that
um and for some reason we kind of train
it out of ourselves to start thinking
linearly
about things so in the sense yeah the
early early basic math
is uh yeah it forces us to take a step
back
it's it's the same criticism if there's
any of science
is the lessons of science
make us like see the world in a slightly
narrow sense
to where we we have an over-exaggerated
confidence that we understand everything
as opposed to just understanding a small
slice of it
but i think that probably only really
goes for small numbers because the real
counterintuitive thing about exponential
growth is like as the numbers start to
get big
so i bet if you took that same set up
and you asked them oh if i keep tripling
the size of this rock pile you know um
seven times how big will it be
i bet it would be surprisingly big even
to like an
a society without numeracy and that's
the side of it that um
i think is pretty counterintuitive to us
but that
you can basically train into people like
i think computer scientists and
physicists
when they're looking at the early
numbers of um like
covid were they were the ones thinking
like oh god this is following an exact
exponential curve
yeah um and i heard that from a number
of people
uh so it's and almost all of them are
like techies in some capacity
probably just because i like live in the
bay area but but for sure they they're
cognizant of this kind of
this kind of growth is present a lot of
natural systems and a lot of
in a lot of in a lot of systems uh i
don't know if you've seen like i mean
there's a lot of ways to visualize this
obviously but rayker as well
i think was the one that had this like
chess board
where uh every every square in the
chessboard you double the number of
stones or something in that chess board
i've heard this is like an old proverb
where you know someone the king offered
him a gift and he said uh
the only gift i would like very modest
give me a single grain of rice
right so the first chessboard and then
two grains of rice for the next square
then twice that for the next square and
just continue on that's my only modest
ask your sire
and like it's all you know more grains
of rice than there are
anything in the world by the time you
get to the end and i
i my intuition falls apart there like i
would have never predicted that
like for some reason that's a really
compelling
illustration how poorly breaks down just
like you said
maybe we're okay for the first few piles
but of rocks
but after a while it's game over you
know the other
classic example for um gauging someone's
intuitive understanding of exponential
growth
is uh i've got like a lily pad on a on
lake really big lake okay
um like lake michigan and that lily pad
replicates it doubles
um one day and then it doubles the next
day and it doubles the next day
and after 50 days it actually is going
to cover the entire lake
okay so after how many days does it
cover half the lake
49. so you you have a good instinct for
exponential growth right
so i think a lot of like the knee-jerk
reaction is sometimes to think that it's
like
half the amount of time or to at least
be like surprised
that like after 49 days you've only
covered half of it
um yeah i mean that's the reason you
heard a pause from me
i literally thought that can't be right
right yeah exactly
so even when you know the fact and you
do the division it's like
wow so you've gone like that whole time
and then day 49 it's only covering half
and then after that it gets the whole
thing
but i think you can make that even more
visceral if rather than going one day
before you say how long
until um it's covered one percent of the
lake right
and it's uh so what would that be um how
many times you have to double to get
over
a hundred like seven six and a half
times something like that
right so at that point you're looking at
43 44 days into it you're not even at
one percent of the lake
so you've you've experienced you know 44
out of 50 days and you're like ah that
lily bad it's just one percent of the
lake
but then next thing you know it's the
entire lake
you